Frederick Krueger later known as Fred or
most commonly Freddy was born in the
early 1940s was the son of a nun named
Amanda Krueger she was part of a
religious order that ran an asylum known
as Weston Hills and did volunteer work
there from time to time when Amanda was
young she was accidentally locked in a
ward for the criminally insane over the
holidays and the inmates kept her hidden
for days when she was found she was
barely alive and now pregnant with a
child Freddy according to Alice
Johnson's research on Freddy Amanda gave
birth at that very same Asylum I imagine
she delivered the baby here as opposed
to a normal hospital out of Shame since
nuns are supposed to be celibate she was
panicked throughout the entire
childbirth and the baby was breach
meaning that he was going to come out
feet first instead of head first there's
probably some symbolism surrounding the
fact that Freddy was born upside down
with the mother being a nun and an
upside down cross being associated with
the devil because through his disastrous
life experiences and eventual demonic
intervention Freddy would indeed become
the antithesis to God